et la russie va encore plus loin
puisqu'elle dit avoir ouvert un couloir
permettant aux forces du creden de
marioupol de sortir bonjour michel aulas
garde et merci d'être en direct sur
france 24 vous êtes ancien commandant de
l'école navale ancien commandant du
porte hélicoptères jeanne d'arc d'abord
on assiste à quel genre d'offensive
spécifiquement aérienne dans le donbass
ou aussi au sol ce serait plutôt la
préparation d'une grande offensive
terrestre car le terrain il faut
l'occuper pour être vainqueur simplement
pour l'instant aux assistants à la
préparation d'une offensive comme savent
les faire et russe s'est d'ailleurs look
très grande force c'est à dire un tapis
de bombes un tapis de d'obus et cela
présage une grande offensive qui sera
menée vraisemblablement par le nord car
par l'est la ligne de front du dombass
102 stabilisé depuis très longtemps déjà
donc il semble bien que même avec
l'apport des forces russes jusqu'à
présent à ces républiques séparatistes
cette ligne a tenu donc il ne peut y
avoir rupture que s'il ya une agression
véritable est donc une guerre de
mouvement désormais qui viendrait du
nord ou du sud voilà dont la carte
alors il n'y a pas que le don bassin qui
est représenté sur cette carte
absolument les zones contrôlées par les
troupes russes sont en rouge ya encore
des zones de résistance mario paul donne
y est ce que
donnée est que non puisque donetsk est
contrôlée par les séparatistes pro
russes mais on voit bien la stratégie
d'encerclement que les russes voudrait
établir voilà cette ligne ici si vous la
voyez c'est la ligne de résistance qui
existe depuis pas mal de temps ici c'est
mario paul les forces sont tout à fait
occuper forces russes ont occupé à
combattre les résistances de mario paul
donc sont relativement épuisé il va
falloir qu'elles reprennent des forces
et il va falloir les renforcer soit par
la crimée par ici soit directement par
la part la russie continental la folle à
la gare de mouvements elle s'amorce
depuis le nord puisque depuis kiev là
bas les forces russes sont retirés après
un échec il faut bien appeler c'est un
véritable échec essaient de contourner
maintenant kharkiv qui est par ici pour
acquis et bombardée depuis est bombardé
mais qui mobilise aussi beaucoup de
force alors ils vont continuer à
bombarder karkhiv pour mobiliser pour
fixer des forces du craignant qu'ils ne
pourraient pas redescendre donc ici
l'offensive devrait se dérouler de cette
façon-là vers la vie le disions que vous
voyez ici pour essayer d'en fermer les
forces du craignent n une grande partie
des forces d'ukrainiens qui sont
extrêmement combative et tout à fait à
la hauteur et qui ont très bien résisté
jusqu'à présent mais ceux qui se
risqueraient de se retrouver dans une
position délicate la seule chose et là
je vous parle est doux de guerre de
mouvement qui paraît étrange c'est
qu'ils savent il semble bien que il y
est une espèce de contre-offensive à
vérifier des forces d'ukrainiens ici
entre l'arrivée par le nord des forces
russes qui attaquent is you et donc
obligatoirement
attaquer leurs lignes logistiques et
leurs lignes d'approvisionnement si cela
se vérifiait ce serait
cela montrerait que les ukrainiens n'ont
pas été inactif pendant tout ce temps
pendant le temps où les russes ont
reconstitué leurs forces pour attaquer
par le nord et oui ça fait plusieurs
jours qu'on annonce cette offensive bien
sûr mais il ne pouvait pas le faire est
ce que il a fallu quand même ils ont eu
une vingtaine de milliers de blessés au
moins deux deux morts au moins autant de
blessés une armée qui perd autant de
personnel et autant de matériel il faut
beaucoup de temps pour reconstituer
d'autant qu'il faut ensuite la
transporter du dossier de kiev à
kharkhiv et ses environs donc là nous
avons peut-être le début d'une guerre de
mouvement qui vient
sensiblement changé la donne de la
guerre de positions que nous avions
jusqu'à présent et qui montre combien
cette armée ukrainienne a changé de
niveau et peut-être même de capacité de
résistance et de contre attaquer le
dombass est une région assez urbanisées
finalement avec plusieurs grandes villes
est ce que ça c'est un handicap pour les
russes il semble que ce soit un handicap
sauf que les russes ne s'en préoccupe
pas beaucoup pour nous organiser ça
voudrait dire tenter d'éviter les effets
collatéraux ce n'est pas du tout leur
culture on l'a vu d'ailleurs à marioupol
qui semble être détruite à 80 90 % donc
normalement ça serait une handicap s'il
fallait livrer des combats urbains pour
lesquelles il semble ne pas avoir été
très bien formés et qu'ils seront très
très difficile à mener mais
on peut craindre le pire on peut
craindre le pire parce que c'est très
urbanisé parce que très industrialisé la
richesse une des richesses de l'ukraine
se trouve dans le donbass et donc nous
pouvons craindre des pertes civiles
extraordinairement élevé parce que
justement
le général qui a à qui on a confié le
commandement cette zone est surnommé
quand même le boucher d'alep en syrie
donc on imagine tout de suite là la
tactique qu'il va utiliser avec des
bombardements jour et nuit un sur 60 sur
les bâtiments sur les immeubles tout à
fait car cela concourt aussi à épuiser
la population à faire fuir la population
à à mettre beaucoup de réfugiés sur les
routes ce qui est très difficile à gérer
pour la partie ukrainienne aussi la
grande inconnue c'est l'état des forces
du craignent haine qui ne communique pas
sur le nombre de morts ni de blessés et
donc le soutien international en matière
d'armement et de renseignement ça
pourrait être crucial dans cette
nouvelle bataille il est crucial et
espérons qu'il est déjà arrivé parce que
il ya aussi une élongation sert une
distance extrêmement grande entre le
vivent qui est à l'ouest du pays par
lequel transite enfin dans cette région
là à peu près tous les tous les renforts
en matériel qui viennent de l'occident
et puis ni pro qui est la base arrière
si vous voulez des combats ukrainien
dans john bass donc il faudrait que ces
forces là que ces matériels là soit déjà
en place car il est vraisemblable que
maintenant tout ce qui va transiter vers
l'est du pays risquent fort d'être
attaqué en particulier par l'aviation
russe on se concentre maintenant sur
l'est de l'ukraine est ce que les russes
néanmoins ont la capacité technique
physique de lancer d'autres offensives
notamment sur la capitale sur kiev alors
cela semble peu probable pour l'instant
parce que comme vous l'avez vu ils se
sont retirés ça a pris beaucoup de temps
pour reconstituer leurs forces et c'est
maintenant lorsque les russes si les
russes parce qu'on ne sait jamais
comment va se dérouler sa wii parce
qu'il ya d'autres bombardements la wii
mais il ya deux nuits sur kiev ils
maintiennent la terreur ça c'est normal
c'est pour épuiser la résistance la
volonté du peuple fais pas pour avancer
mais une fois que les russes
éventuellement
seront bien implanté dans les deux
oblast en dans le dos de basses dans en
crimée et ayant créé ce corridor la
personne ne peut imaginer même pendant
des négociations même si des
négociations aboutissent que les russes
ne voulant pas se venger de cette
terrible humiliation qu'ils ont sur bus
jusqu'à présent et il est possible qu'un
jour ou l'autre que pendant tout ce
temps restent dans leurs pensées cette
envie de conquérir davantage d'ukraine
et de mettre à genoux ce régime qui leur
a tant jc un dernier mot sur mario paul
est de ville qui continue de résister
qui n'est toujours pas tombée il y
aurait encore 3000 soldats ukrainien
retranchées dans un complexe industriel
c'est la priorité de poutine ce serait
un objectif minimal finalement la prise
de mario paul dans le donbass oui et
c'est très étonnant
pour l'instant ce qu'on pouvait dire en
voyant cette ville détruite à 80 90 %
c'est que mario paul en fait était tombé
et que il restait que cette usine
azoff talent avec ses milliers de
combattants du régiment azoff et puis
nous avons eu des des communications du
vice maire de la ville qui dit mais non
la ville résiste alors on ne sait pas
très bien qui résistent ou mais il ya
une poche de résistance énorme dans
cette usine mais ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est que toute la ville de mario pole
dance ou en dessous de toute la ville de
barrio paul ya à peu près 20 kilomètres
de souterrains et de tunnels qui ne sont
pas simplement qu'ils ne se limite pas
simplement aux souterrains au tunnel que
l'on supposait être juste sous cette
usine il y a donc un réseau dans lequel
il ya des civils qui sont cachés des
civils qui sont protégés il y a des bien
sûr des possibilités de d'entrer dans ce
réseau de souterrains ou d'en partir les
russes connaissent très bien ces
souterrains puisque c'est sous le régime
soviétique qui ont été construits donc
nous ne savons pas du tout ce qui se
passe dans la termitière ce qui a
certainement c'est que dans l' usine à
geof talent en surface il ya des soldats
ukrainien car vous ne pouvez pas vous
enfermés sous terre et puis rester
l'arbre est donc il y à des combats des
combats très difficile menée dans une
dans une configuration très urbaine un
peu comme celle dont à laquelle nous
faisions allusion c'est très difficile à
prendre
donc ces combats là tant qu'ils dureront
en surface pourront
permettre à la résistance iranienne de
résister assez longtemps parce que ça
permet aussi une relève des combattants
qui peuvent se restaurer qui peuvent se
reposer en dessous si voilà c'est
peut-être un peu un rêve de de stratégie
militaire mais il n'empêche que healy à
cela il ya cette résistance peut-on dire
que la ville de mario paul et est
entièrement sous contrôle russe eh bien
écoutez ça n'est pas certain parce qu'on
ne sait pas ce qui se passe sous terre
en particulier merci beaucoup pour ces
précisions michel aulas garage